la fusion après de convoyage j'ai bien
aimé ça c'est admirable
si vous avez la propreté la chute
actuelle j'ouvre la bouche de son
oppression merveilleux merveilleux
oui le métro les commentaires et le lieu
de ces montréalais qui venait
d'effectuer claudine leur tout premier
voyage en métro c'était il ya cinquante
ans le 14 octobre 1966 donc montréal
quand prénom la modernité avec un métro
tout neuf 20 stations le deuxième et aux
canadiens après toronto le premier en
amérique du nord a roulé sur
pneumatiques l'aboutissement de plus de
50 ans de débats d'études de projets a
battu au conseil municipal le premier
projet de réseau ferroviaire sous
terrain remonte à 1912
trop cher trop compliqué est arrivée la
grande crise de 1929 et la deuxième
guerre mondiale
donc on roulait en tramway qu'on a
retirés de la circulation à 59 et
remplacés par des autobus juge est
beaucoup plus moderne
une décision que les partisans
aujourd'hui encore du tramway regrette
toujours
donc il a fallu attendre l'élection du
maire jean drapeau en 1960 pour que le
projet se concrétise jean-drapeau dont
on a dit que c'était la plus grande
réussite mais le maire n'était pas au
départ un un fervent défenseur du métro
il croyait comme d'autres que les
transports collectifs collectif c'était
peut-être dépassé de 5 ans j'allais pas
parce que c'était le début du règne de
l'automobile qui incarnait la mondiale
monte la liberté le symbole aussi d'une
classe moyenne émergente
le jean drapeau bleu même construire une
autoroute sur le mont royal alors c'est
dire et finalement c'est son bras droit
le président du comité exécutif lucien
saulnier qui la convertit au projet
faut dire que toronto donc avait déjà
son métro depuis 1954 alors concurrencer
montréal ne voulait pas perdre son
statut de métropole
et puis il y avait des problèmes de
congestion routière a requis peuvent
peut-être nous paraître dérisoire
aujourd'hui mais qu'on jugeait déjà à
l'époque invivable
voici à ce sujet un extrait de reportage
de 1961 signé par pierre nadeau chaque
jour aux heures de pointe dans les
grandes artères qui conduisent le coeur
la métropole
les automobilistes mais et camionneurs
les cyclistes et les piétons se cherche
un trou de souris pour pouvoir gagner la
course pour mon temps
et même à l'intérieur d'un véhicule
l'individu sans qu'il n'ait qu'une fois
les cultes
on se dévisagent sans se voir
on rêve à l'heure de solutions
énergiques sans oublier de jeter tout le
blâme sur les amis ce trader de la cité
même les plus un frère de l'île déserte
tous les malheureux chauffeur en
j'y reste
faire qu'ils envient les épouses qui
restent à l'aller se cherche un trou de
souris
très attendue la poésie d'en parler d'un
bouchon de circulation ces phénomènes et
malgré les problèmes de circulation donc
le métro en 1961 ne fait pas l'unanimité
pour ou contre le métro la question se
pose à l'époque la journaliste andré
anne laffont
la pause était à quelques citoyens
faites vous pour ou contre le métro on
aura maintenant est ce que ça vous
apportera avoue savourer le trafic
serait
ça voudrait plus pourquoi parce que j'ai
mes trousses avantage est repassé de mon
talent taj mahal le monde est emballé
alors quand je passe tellement magique
adige et la fée des étoiles vitry temps
par ailleurs mais nos chauffeurs des tec
10 à change plus c'est pareil on se rend
compte de son équipe les opposants aussi
au projet dit que ça allait coûter trop
cher la ville a quand même débloqué un
budget de 130 2 millions à l'est pas
pour deux lignes un budget qui est passé
à 214 millions l'année suivante banc
pour l'ajout de la ligne vers sainte
hélène et longueuil après besoin l'expo
donc des travaux herculéens vraiment
sont entrepris il faut creuser sans
endommager les bâtiments à la surface on
construise être 25 pieds de tunnels par
jour 210 pied par semaine et les
échéances ont été respectées et de
l'océan sur quatre ans des tonnes et des
tonnes de terre et de roches qui vont
servir en partie à créer l'île notre
dame et agrandir l'île sainte hélène
pour l'expo 67 donc inauguration du
métro a lieu à la station berri de
montigny va nommer berri uqam 88 le
maire jean drapeau au président la
cérémonie à laquelle participe le
premier ministre du québec daniel
johnson et bien sûr le cardinal paul
emile léger qui bénit le métro millions
de personnes en font l'essai pendant la
toute première fête semaine
d'exploitation un passage ordinaire que
18 cents aujourd'hui ces trois de
l'arménie
alors voici quelques commentaires
recueillis par le journaliste claude
jean de virieu
la pièce est devant nous de vie très
enthousiasmant c'est formidable très
moderne et très très bouge très vite
tellement d'amis revisitons merci
monsieur de notation à mon agression
c'est parmi la mairie de paris
je suis là tabou qui se représente pour
vous la rénovation du métro tv se
mouiller pour s ils exercent elles y ont
versé